[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
reggie aloysius miller junior iii
the hall of famer yay
[Music]
look who's back
hey how you doing
everyone's gotta have seen music when
they've been away from
the theodore patrick show so baby i'm
back
and and baby is somewhere in the back
room right
the new baby yeah baby is back how is
the baby doing
the baby is doing great it's funny
because everyone's like
where have you been we've missed you
on the damn patrick show i tell people
number one covid
covet baby covet baby
um and i've been on a long paternity
leave that's all i said
i'm coming back i just got an extended
fraternity leave
from the theodore patrick show that's
all people we're back together the
family's back together
we were worried that you were still
going to be at the wendy's house and
that that you weren't taking care of
your kids so i'm glad that you left the
wendy's house and you're taking care of
the kid you didn't name your baby wendy
right no you didn't okay
she is not she is not named wendy okay i
know
all right uh no but i'm taking care of
my kids um as
all responsible fathers do and
not only are not in the wendy's again
i'm not in the wendy's in orlando
because the last time we spoke
through i was stuck in orlando in the
bubble yeah
so uh now i'm back home in california
working remotely still harlan and i we
still call games remotely
um i'll be glad once hopefully playoffs
start there'll be a little bit more
interaction
um but we are still working remotely for
those of you who follow the nba
but we're still having a great time are
you traveling during the playoffs do you
know yet
we will be traveling to atlanta to call
games
hopefully by the conference finals which
this year
turner has the eastern conference finals
depending on the matchup in the two
teams hopefully we will be on site
that still remains up in the air i
applaud uh
turner and warner media for wanting to
keep us safe
um we miss the interaction with the fans
and being there
in person but it's always about safety
first
um at turner and warner media so
we're taking that approach reggie will
be on the call with kevin harlan that'll
be thursday night lakers and the
clippers
uh let me start with the lakers here if
you were a betting man
the odds of the lakers defending their
title
going back to the finals is what
to me it's all about health and
if lebron and a.d are healthy
um the lakers are always the team to
beat now i know lebron has been back two
games in their own two since he has
returned
and they just have not looked well and
now i'm hearing reports out
lebron saying whoever came up with this
playoff format ought to be fired
where was all this talk a month ago two
months ago when
the lakers when boston
when dallas they were securely one of
the top
six teams now they're on the outside
possibly looking in
i know dallas and the lakers are like
five and six
with portland being seven all three of
those teams are tied
uh it's a little bit of crying because
the whole point of the play-in
was to make sure regular season games
mattered so take care of your business
during the regular season
finish one through six so you can rest
theodore
rest that week and let those other teams
battle it out
lebron goes down ad goes down and now
they're kind of
on a nosedive looking at
seven through 10. so i don't want to
hear all the crying if you would have
took care of
business now i know injuries are a part
of it but i don't want to hear
that oh my god the plan one through six
you rest
here is lebron james talking about the
the play in games
and i don't know if he knows that he's
taking a shot at the commissioner
well it doesn't matter at the end of the
day if i'm not uh you know 100 percent
close to 100 it don't matter
you know where we land you know so
you know that's my mindset and you know
if this happens to uh we end up at sixth
or fifth or or
whatever the case may be or we end up in
a you know the playoff
uh whatever that thing is whoever came
up with that
need to be fired um but whatever uh
lebron i'm gonna guess the commissioner
would like to talk to you
he's the one who came up with the idea
theodore he's right
because i agree with him if he finishes
if the lakers finish seven
eight nine or ten odds on
with lebron and a.d they're gonna win
their games who i feel sorry for
if i'm phoenix or utah
i don't want to see lebron and 80
possibly in the first round
that's who should be upset about this if
they happen to fall seven through two
and anthony davis since he came back
this is six games
has really not had an impact uh shooting
under 40 percent average in 16 points
lakers have been outscored
by 56 points when he's on the court
uh the worst plus minus on the team
almost double of the second worst there
it's not just lebron it's a.d and as we
talked about last year i said
as great as lebron is they're not
winning a title without a.d and i
certainly feel
that way but if you're going to handicap
the west because we do this we'll look
at hey they were a great regular season
team
i don't think anybody's bought into the
utah jazz nationally you know
wonderful year uh denver i don't know if
anybody's bought into them
phoenix i don't know if anybody's bought
into them where you go you know what
if they meet with the lakers they'll
beat them now out of those three teams
who has the best if you want to throw
the clippers in there to who has the
best
chance of going to the western
conference finals or playing in the
the championship at the end of the day
and again
i will stress health health is of
the utmost importance let's say
everybody's healthy lakers everyone
it will oh to me it will always come
down to the lakers and clippers okay
because they've got bonafide superstars
on both sides
they've got lockdown defense again the
the lakers
even though a.d and lebron missed so
much time they were still a top
four defensive team even without those
two superstars
at the end of the day kawhi paul george
a.d lebron they're the two best teams
because
i've seen their body of work in the
playoffs
um sometimes with the clippers for kauai
in san antonio and toronto i'm going to
go with the clippers and the lakers at
the
end of the day and everyone is healthy
and healthy
but again that hasn't been the case this
year so the three teams you mentioned
phoenix utah and denver they somewhat
scare me because
i think denver is playing much better
people like well they're going to be
without jamal murray because of the
injury
i think they're better defensively now
and
jokic in my opinion the mvp this year so
denver is a scary team it would be a
scary out
and on top of that we'll have home court
advantage you've got to go there
all the way up and probably until the
conference finals because one of those
two spots would probably be phoenix
or utah that will have home court
advantage throughout the western
conference
i was wondering and i try not to you
know delve into the mvp
topic uh normally because i think you
know a lot of host
uh shows are trolling you because it's
lebron if lebron's involved in the
conversation then this is a big deal
joker winning the mvp nobody cares
nationally about this
even if it's joel embiid nobody cares
nationally if lebron and james harden
are in it
then you can at least have an arguing
point chris paul to me
right in in true value to a team not the
best player
but true value to a team i can't dismiss
that a lot of times we look at the stats
that you throw in there and you go well
he's the mvp
i'm just looking at value and i can't
i can't argue chris paul being a
legitimate mvp candidate
why is he not considered you know one of
the top five
and certainly let's put in if phoenix
finishes and ends up
the number one seed in the west because
no one saw that saw this coming yeah
and let's remember now what phoenix did
in bubble life in orlando going 8-0
and pushing those teams and and narrowly
missing out
on making the playoffs in orlando so
what has money williams done he's gone
out and gotten the best leader
arguably in the game in chris paul
and they have bought in to
everything that he has said now again it
remains to be seen what's going to
happen
in the playoffs but i absolutely agree
with you that chris paul needs to be
getting
more love for the mvp talk now he's not
the best player on that team
the closer and the best player on the
team is devin booker and i think that's
what's kind of going to hurt him because
they will take
votes away from one another but in terms
of value
the words you use and in a team
buying in to a system into a player and
believing
now they are a young team for a team to
believe
and that's all spearheaded by the head
of the snake
and chris paul he's reggie miller the
hall of famer back with us and uh he's
on the call thursday night it's lakers
clippers
at 10 eastern on tnt so when you're
doing the games at home
the kitties are in bed by then so
nobody's like walking in when you're
you're doing the game and interrupting
you at home
kevin calls the game from his basement
in kansas city yeah i'm fortunate enough
to be able to go to a studio because
they asked me hey do you want to call
the games from home they gave me that
option i'm like
hello to the
doing knobs because i would be changing
a diaper
as well as blowing noses from two little
kids
there's no way i could functionally call
a two and a half
three hour game with three kids there's
just no way
so i'm fortunate to go to a studio okay
and call the game and
sync up with my partner kevin harlan are
you at your house right now
i'm at my house now where there's
nothing on the walls reg
i'm at my rented house oh okay
i'm just gonna say man there's nothing
here
there's nothing here this is this is the
office of the rigid house
there's a trash bin there's a fax
machine there's michael jackson's hat
that's that's the prize possession in
here michael jackson's
wait uh bring a jean hat but that's it
wait go go get that
that is it bring that over here so this
is the
this is the billie jean head oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
reg has got the michael jackson hat
under gl oh sign
and sign what did that cost you
it was a retirement gift from the
location
[Laughter]
it was a retirement gift from the pacers
how cool
is this you know so when you watch the
video and he sold it out
yeah one of the fedoras right come on
you can't go
this is the number one price of the
jordan jersey
the bird jersey the magic jurors all
them
signed by the great basketball gods
the mount rushmore i'm taking this as my
most
prized possession ever in my house wait
you got a jordan
signed jersey i did i do
okay because you never got along with
him
no who asked for it oh
you think i asked for that no i'll do it
again
hail to the but but you had to ask
somebody to do it
yes okay one of the uh people that
worked for the
uh pacers obviously wanted one and
they're like hey
i'll get you if you can like you know
put a word in i'm like i'm not putting
the word in but
so i sent a ball boy down to the bulls
locker room and says hey
reg is you know there's a friend that
works for the pacers would love your
autograph and
you know him and a friend know if you'll
sign these two
i was the friend you wanted the jersey
did michael want one of your jerseys
okay for the third time hello
mj wanting my jersey no i don't think
jordan has any jerseys on
no i don't think sorry right now just
his bird has any and i don't think
maybe magic does magic is is a hoop or
maybe magic
does but i don't think bird or or or air
jordan has any
are you sold on the knicks like this is
a is this a legitimate feel-good story
with the knicks
i'm absolutely sold i'm so that they can
win a first-round
playoff matchup i think they can get to
the conference semis
they play great defense they have
a bonafide coach and coach thibodeaux
julius randle
most improved no question hands down is
going to probably win at this year
and i think rj barrett is starting to
understand the game
uh they're they play again they're long
they're athletic
it's a great feel good story it's great
to have the number one media market
new york have two good teams to have
brooklyn and new york i think that's
great for the league
um but i think the easter conference is
i think it's wide open i know everyone
wants to lean towards brooklyn
i hope those guys make it to the finish
line you know i know what
you know kd had a great game last night
kyrie's been playing great
we still waiting for harden to come back
he had a little bit of a setback with
the hamstring injury
the team to watch in the east i'm
telling everyone this
they were the most disappointing team
the last two years because they have the
best record
let me see if i can get it oh i just
blew it yeah you just did
okay milwaukee yeah i think
they were never used to being the hunter
right they will always be i think now
that
they're going to go out and be the
hunter instead of the hunted
i think milwaukee is in the best place
because no one's talking about them
they're talking about philly
they're talking about brooklyn and
they're talking about what's wrong with
boston no one's talking about milwaukee
and what did giannis do last night
versus brooklyn and katie puts up 49 in
his return
milwaukee this could be the year explain
to me why the pelicans are so bad
i don't know they play less defense than
i do
reg and you know what it's so
wild because their head coach is all
about defense in stan bank
that's why they brought him in right yes
yes look it's
this is very unique in weird year it
really is there's no practice time
it's all about you have a game every
other day and
it stands first year i'm going to give
them a little bit of a long leash if
they play like this
next season then it's something it's an
area of concern
but it's just been a weird year theodore
and zion
you know he's real you know i'm
wondering
like what does he add to his game
because all great players add
something it feels like almost on a
yearly basis
75 and that's probably i'm probably
exaggerating okay i will say
68 of his shots and field goals come
from in the paint
right you can't stop him so if you can't
stop him out of the paint if he got
a 15 to 18 foot face up jump shot
consistently how are you going to guard
him same like
we say this about giannis too like how
if if he ever got that consistently
yeah how would you guard him because
both have quick first steps
both can jump over you both can handle
the basketball
and both are smart enough to know when
they're doubled in triple team
define the open player he just needs a
face-up jump shot
yeah but why is it one of the great
leapers in the game doesn't have a jump
shot
like he doesn't jump on his jump shot
well
if it ain't broke don't fix it i i look
if they can't stop how he's scoring now
keep going to it yeah where where it
will
come out and where his flaws will be
exposed is if they ever made the
playoffs
because when you make the playoffs and
you get into a series teams take away
your three
best moves three best plays what you do
the best
and that's when we would see if if zion
is able to adapt
to playoff basketball if you lose one of
the three
on brooklyn for an extended amount of
time in the playoffs
who could they afford to lose for an
extended period of time
probably
probably james harden because we're kind
of seeing that now
i think they can't afford to lose kd for
an extended period of time
because he is arguably the best player
in my opinion in the league
and he's a closer kyrie would be second
because
of his ball handling and shot making
ability
and i think when james harden does
eventually return
he is going to take on the de facto
point guard he's going to defer a lot
and score when he he needs to but i
think he'll be the bonafide
true point guard on this team once he
does return but
to me james harden would be the third
person if you had to lose him for
extended period of time
i think the nets would still be
successful with kd and kyrie
it's great to see you great to have you
back and uh reds will be with us
throughout the playoffs there lakers
clippers at 10
eastern on thursday night you got your
michael jack do you know the whole dance
routine
don't pull a hamstring there
these 55 year old ladies and gentlemen
oh i know
i know uh great to have you back we'll
talk to you
next week love you guys love you love
you
reggie aloysius miller jr iii